the tempting of aoc
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now shortly after she stunned house
democrats by beating long-time incumbent
queens congressman
joe crowley two years ago alexandria
ocasio-cortez
was being written off by many
republicans as just a flash in the pan
just a far left progressive who caught
an old establishment democrat off guard
but i saw things differently i think
it's a mistake for conservatives not to
take her seriously to brush her off as
kind of a flash in the pan or an upstart
she's as close to a thought leader that
the democratic party has today
and she has a massive social media
following
she's both charismatic and she's
committed to transforming both our
economic system
and our culture
and while her candidate bernie sanders
didn't win
the 2020 nomination alexandria
ocasio-cortez has had
enormous influence on her party as a
freshman democrat her coalition helped
pull joe biden and her colleagues to the
left
on key issues such as the green new deal
health care and impeachment and
democrats will do almost
anything albeit grudgingly to avoid
being primaried by her one of her
choices
she's presented herself as a strong
voice for
working class americans and a strong
critic
of multinational corporations i'm proud
to be a bartender
ain't nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with working retail
folding clothes for other people to buy
there is nothing wrong with being a
working person in the united states
of america and there is everything
dignified
about it the democratic party is
supposed
to be the champion of the working class
i agree but with joe biden waiting in
the wings poised to announce major
changes to u.s trade and foreign policy
aoc faces some difficult choices
how can she who's always claimed to be a
crusader for the working class you just
heard it
support the policies favored by big
corporate interests wall street
and working people are put last in
washington
day in and day out
well given what biden's team is already
telling us that's exactly where we're
going
backward to the days where the rich get
their way
and the working class gets shafted we're
all seeing
real wage gains average median household
income rose more than six
thousand dollars after decades of wage
stagnation
a focus by president trump on the
american worker protecting american
manufacturing
and holding china and other trade sheets
accountable
that helped him grow his support among
working-class americans this election
including
more latinos black men and asian
americans
now those people did not have to like
his tweets
to love his results the economy got way
better
under the obama administration
unemployment went double from six
from eight to 16. under president trump
they got to the lowest ever been
recorded
in u.s history yeah we need trump
forever
but all the gains that our workers made
are about to be wiped out if
biden's new globalist cabal has its way
they're already sharpening their knives
to cut wages and
ship jobs offshore this raises the
question
will aoc and the squad stand mute while
american workers are crushed
under this agenda or will they work with
american populace to resist
anti-worker policies here are a few
examples of where she could work with
republicans
to block corporatist dems number one
the trans-pacific partnership biden's
handlers want him to jump back
into this trade agreement that trump
nixed well trump was right it's a job
killer
before the pandemic we had the strongest
economy in the g7
and record low unemployment and we still
do
the last thing we need is a jobs-killing
trade deal
no matter what biden's guru's claim
ruining lives of working people here
will not give us more
influence in asia so if you're a
democrat and you somehow think the tpp
was a miss trump opportunity recall what
hillary clinton said about it
in 2016. i will stop
any trade deal that kills jobs or holds
down
wages including the trans-pacific
partnership
well hillary knew that working-class
voters didn't want this deal because
they knew it would mean lower wages for
them and fewer jobs at home
there's a great chance for aoc here and
she should take it by the way national
review
is also for the tpp should that should
give her some solace
number two enforce the usmca now aoc
voted against it which was an
unfortunate mistake
it was because of climate issues but she
could still insist that its
labor provisions at the very least are
honored so we force more
auto production here in the united
states that's good for american workers
now number three uh continue to weaken
the world trade organization
ocasio-cortez could insist that u.s
trade policy
be made here by americans and four
americans
after all she's a member of congress so
why would she want to give
away congressional power over trade she
shouldn't
now number four aoc could insist that
the next u.s trade rep
be a populist not a corporatist
heck i know this seems bizarre or never
going to happen but
she might even consider inviting trump's
ustr
ambassador robert lighthizer to lunch
he's brilliant
he knows all the tricks of multinational
corporations
and i think they'd actually both enjoy
the exchange no harm
and number five she could work to
accelerate efforts to decouple
up from china both economically and
politically
her caucus members support human rights
and china is among the worst
offenders in the world why should our
free economy be open to their worker
abusing companies
and finally number six she could form a
coalition with
key conservatives and some democrats to
urge that we
bring our troops home finally from the
middle east
if progressives are truly anti-war then
they must not be silent as a bipartisan
establishment
urges urging that we still send troops
overseas and stop
troop withdrawals now all six of these
steps
would be popular with congresswoman
ocasio-cortez's supporters
on the left and if she doubts that
all she has to do is talk to unions like
the steel workers and the uaw or ask
young millennials
whether they think we should still be
sending troops to kandahar
i know what many of you were thinking
though this is all
come on laura this is just all a pipe
dream
but i'm not sure aoc has already shown a
willingness
on some issues to work with
conservatives she and ted cruz signed a
letter they kind of snipe on twitter
sometimes but
they signed the letter criticizing apple
for removing a pro hong kong
app also slam the nba for putting its
profits from china
over free speech rights they also want
to work together to rein in lobbyists
but look who's bidens look who's on
biden's transition team
according to the wall street journal at
least 40 people serving on
president-elect joe biden's transition
team
are or were once registered lobbyists
now the establishment usually wins
because the establishment
has enough money to buy off candidates
with fat donations and instant celebrity
status
now remember donald trump didn't get the
flattering magazine covers and neither
did the first lady despite her grace and
beauty
because neither agreed to play ball most
people
aren't strong enough to resist the
temptation
but this is an old tactic by the elites
remember back in 1998 hillary got
glamour shots in vogue
then huma abedin remember her she was in
vogue in
2007 and of course susan rice
got her shot in 2013.
it's always the same play ball on the
economic issues
don't interfere with globalization or
maybe even help out with outsourcing
and we'll make you a star we'll give you
the cultural power to beat up on
conservatives
but when it comes to money and foreign
policy we expect you to go along with
the global elites
so hillary and huma and susan they all
thought
probably they were going to help the
working people too but in the end
the rich got richer and china got
stronger
and the working people well they turned
to donald trump
so it's going to be interesting to see
aoc's next move
in the last few months the establishment
has shown her the carrot
the cover of vanity fair of course and
the stick
leaks about how aoc is hurting the
democrat party
so if she goes along on the china and
trade issue and helps the tech bros get
richer
well she'll have a one-way ticket with
the in-crowd
and if she leaves politics they'll make
her an instant multi-millionaire
but if she stands up to the
establishment on china and if she fights
against the tpp
if she tries to end foolish wars
well then she'll get very different
treatment well the choice is hers
and she'll have to make it soon by
working with the populace she can really
help working people
and for many folks that's even better
than being on the cover of vogue
or vanity fair and that's the angle